non
la vanne bien messieurs s'il vous plaît
vos premières questions bien d'abord
bonjour monsieur madame madame princesse
j'aurai une question d'abord c'est pour
pour jour de france un jour une question
d'abord un cesse vous allez de se voir
bon nombre de vos admirateurs en
devenant la femme d'un seul homme
maintenant et j'aimerais savoir si je ne
pensais pas que votre cote de popularité
risque de baisser
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout le monde
qui ça vous dirait on me faudra
s'habituer mon vieux un petit sourire là
pour la vie du rail
merci une question du journal mon tricot
est-ce que vous avez l'attention depuis
que tu es vous même la layette de votre
futur enfant
ben voyons c'est bien connu qu'on a pas
assez de fric pour s'acheter des
fringues suivant
francis huster de la vie ouvriers 20 ans
voilà une question qui me brûle les
lèvres de faites vous de vos journées
princesse comment sortent et monsieur on
ne répondra pas ce genre de questions
non mais on fait rien mais personne a
besoin de le savoir
votre sainteté est ce que vous pourriez
reprendre la position sortait la cour je
suis partout je vous prie
sortez monsieur jean question mois sous
placées pour la vie la vie catholique le
journal du saint-père à moi j'en aurais
eu aussi c'est pour la vie catholique
c'est un journal de télé j'en ai vu
menacer la vie chaotique le journal de
véhicules tout terrain alors oui gros p
vous et c'est le reflet
sur la neige non ainsi dans un petit
sourire s'il vous plaît la princesse
pour le nouvel exécuteur merci j'ai une
question pour paris match s'il vous
plaît pendant votre nuit de noce nous
étions avec eux enfin des copains on
était dans la chambre à côté donc on a
eu le poids des monuments bien voix
chaude des photos mais non ce pouvoir de
polaroïd alors écoutez monsieur des
photos cochonnes seront en vente après
la réunion jeudi ce qui ferait des coûts
qui va bien là on va laisser le macaroni
répondre et quoique ai demandé vous ai
demandé où étaient les toilettes
sur les toiles étaient à côté à côté on
s'en détourner de notre côté voilà c'est
bien il commence à savoir répondre aux
énigmes dans la foulée dans la foulée
j'aimerais poser une autre question pour
le journal dans la foulée comment avez
vous fait pour séduire pauline oui et
aurions alors je suis arrivé avec la
voiture la lame en guinée je suis arrivé
on donne j'avais deux styles c'est comme
ça c'est comme en effet quand j'ai vu
pauline avec eux si je me suis avancé et
la lave et la glace est le bijou est
heureux je vais rester le voyez comme ça
apolline apolline hightower je serais tu
veux que l'on doit faire le point de la
ferrari lamborghini maserati viens on va
les manger de nos impôts comme il allait
me suis mis à chanter au lit on n'est
pas là
vous pourriez vous pourriez reprendre la
foulée pour la vie du rail la software
merci oui alors j'aurai une question là
pour le journal de la de l'almanach
vermot maintenant dit est ce que vous
avez vu monte carlo
mais monsieur nous connaissons monte
carlo est évidemment question suivante
s'il vous plaît pour le pèlerin à 20
centimes les ânes ou là vous pourriez
pas refaire les années passées en
exclusivité ça va venir
c'est bon merci votre sainteté merci une
question de tennis et dont le seul
journal qui rackettent ses lecteurs
j'aimerais savoir et on dit on prétend
c'est vrai un que vous avez fréquenté
pas mal de joueurs de tennis ne pas je
veux pas citer de noms mais par exemple
guillermo vilas john mcenroe ivan lendl
jimmy connors borotra lacoste
pesci bornes noah enfin bon non non non
non excusez moi à vous n'avez pas fait
quand tu es noir et on peut savoir
pourquoi
écoutez j'ai un certain rang qui ne
m'autorise pas à fréquenter des gens qui
ne sont pas noble
je suis clairement toujours et je peux
dire que noah vient d'acheter une
particule il s'appelle maintenant notre
concours
la classe et vous avez la bonne c'est
vraiment moi du pic et est all
tortellinis la question une petite pause
pour le trou normand s'il vous plaît en
exclusivité le sourire voilà la question
oui une question pour issy paris s'il
vous plaît pas la question est une
simple formalité parce que l'article est
sorti ce matin
alors je vais savoir bon camp lorsque
vous avez prononcé le oui fatidique
est ce que c'est vrai que vous étiez en
cloque enceinte de six mois ces envois
six mois mois qui sait si moi c'est des
beatles c'est moi je l'aimé assad
moi je vais le casser la gueule qui sait
si d or c'est moi alors je donne deux
mois près de chez moi
heureusement qu'il a du blé parce qu'il
est ancien qu'est-ce que je dois
princesse est ce que je dois comprendre
que voulait pas répondre à la question
si je veux répondre à la question je
n'étais absolument pas enceinte de six
mois n'est ni d'eau claire mois vous
n'étiez pas enceinte
s'il n'est pas ça ok alors pour le
croissance et comme d'habitude on
connaissait la quadrette pose une
question là de journal couvert de
montagne l'humanité et comme là est ce
que vous osez dépensés par mois par
rapport à notre ère les aciers poissy
pardon qui gagne mais heureusement le
smic pénible emma accord ce qui la font
le choix des pneus dans un palais demain
à la place d'une hlm
dites moi c'est un peu là vont tout cela
derrière à vous tous vos bijoux à vos
bagues aux lots falbala on ne répondre
qu'aux questions en français
l'autre question oui je voudrais vous
demander pour quelles raisons acceptez
vous de répondre à toutes ces questions
égoutter
on a tellement de choses sur mon cours
de calomnies complètement
j'ai beaucoup de copains évidemment j'ai
beaucoup d'amis comme tout le monde j'ai
beaucoup je vis ma vie je m'occupe des
attentats on est tellement de choses
méchantes sur mon compte que j'ai voulu
remettre les choses au point en pis je
crois qu il énorme de ma ville donc je
vais le crier mon amour au monde entier
j'ai posé ma bombe alors on est entre
copines
alors c'est pour homo et jogging
elle s'en serait douté on va là-bas
question alors ça sera du monte dans la
chair et des dessins j'ai une question
terrible
j'aimerais savoir vous me regardez quand
je vous parle
j'aimerais savoir tels que vous voyez là
comme une grande soeur sauvage qu'est ce
que vous mettez comme dessous
tout est une question relativement
personnel mais c'est pas vrai que je
passais à lui
seniors je n'ai pas de dosso et eau
haulotte bien qu'il
la boucle d'oreille pour chasseurs
d'image là ça marche une fois sur quatre
est embêtant merci suivant pour vsd moi
excusez moi j'ai pas compris vous
pourriez plaît vsd ça veut dire quoi
vendredi samedi dimanche oui bah c'est
trop tard monsieur nous sommes mardi
c'est une question qui vous concerne
vous justement prince doit savoir où
vous avez acheté votre couronne double à
la boulangerie ouais mais la galette est
en sûreté au coffre se terminait
monsieur je vous donne rendez-vous c'est
terminé je vous donne rendez vous dans
trois mois pour le divorce